[Musik]
hallo zusammen heute gibt es drei
frühstücks rezepte dieses video könnt
ihr euch das ganze jahr über ansehen
jetzt gerade an ramadan ist es so dass
man zum star holt das ist quasi dieses
frühstück das ist das letzte mal wenn
man anfängt zu fasten bzw klose ist es
dieses jahr so gegen vier uhr morgens
ich weiß dass viele nicht gerade appetit
haben aber es ist für mich aber ich
finde sie schon super wichtig dass man
was ist dass man auch den tag einfach
gut übersteht die kraft hat und lange
satt bleibt ich mach jetzt zuallererst
overnight oates ich leg direktor sich
häufig an der ganz gesund lecker sowieso
wie immer hier unten in die infobox für
overnight as machen wir eine art
metapher schreiben möchte ich nicht
sagen weil es gar nicht schlimm ich aber
einfach so eine art wie sie mit porridge
aber nicht wirklich politisch sondern es
wird über nacht im kühlschrank es ergibt
einfach nur richtig tolle konsistenz und
ich finde es fast schon leckere also
warm aufgekocht und porridge ich habe
hier kernigen haferflocken ich mache
direkt zwei portionen wir haben
sonnenmilch das könnt ihr super
vorbereiten ihr könnt auch für zwei oder
drei tage vorbereiten wir cd
haferflocken direkt in st der kleine
schüssel und da gebe ich dann noch
leinsamen dazu die geschrotteten und
wenn ihr die nicht mögt dann machst du
jetzt an der stelle einfach weg aber die
sind super gesund und was ich für mich
entdeckt habe ist geprüften quinoa der
ist so lecker kommt auch noch was dazu
letztens habe ich das mal gemacht
morgens da also auch keine fastenzeit
wenn es hat mich sechs stunden lang sagt
gehalten leute denken hey wieso habe ich
heute keinen hunger sonst tritt der
hunger nach vier stunden ein und lag
schon langweilig sagt gibt denn hier
noch vanille extrakt dazu ein bisschen
honig und milch
[Musik]
also anhand der fast leeren vorratsdosen
sieht man dass ich das echt sehr oft es
in letzter zeit und habe sein mag das
auch total haben sie es gar kein
porridge werden muss ich sagen aber
diese obermarkt da fragte sogar selber
jeden tag nach und er das ganze was
natürlich gekühlt werden also überdacht
können auch ganz normal zum stahl ist
also zum fastenbrechen das dann
vorbereitet wir sind das halt irgendwie
vier stunden oder sowas und dann reicht
das auch vorkommt und ihr seht wie sich
die konsistenz filme das ist natürlich
jetzt hier noch alles super flüssig und
alles die die haferflocken sind noch
total kernig und hart aber wenn ihr das
dann richtig kühlt im kühlschrank dann
ergibt dass so eine konsistenz und das
ist schon ein paar will ich schon
richtig hunger das ist schon echt lecker
ich habe das auch teilweise das gefühl
dass etwas verbotenes es weil es ist
gesunden das schmeckt so lecker schmeckt
wie ein bisher also wenn ihr dann quasi
das ganze gekühlt habt dann könnt ihr
euch noch toppings ohne ende drauf
machen alles was sie mögen ich mag das
sonst immer ganz gerne wenn ich irgend
eine creme von mir nehme ich mag die
cocos themen ganz gerne die haselnuss
creme oder auch die
spekuliert aber auch wenn ihr sagt die
möchte sitzt in richtung da hingehen
könnte auch einfach dahin nie drauf
packen und halte früchte granulat alles
was ihr möchtet
[Musik]
wenn ihr mögt dann könnt ihr auf jeden
fall noch neutrales protein pulver dazu
geben falls ihr das da habt so 12 gramm
ungefähr 15 gramm nämlich immer dann
hält es noch länger satt und ihr habt
euch noch mehr weißt aber ich muss sagen
auch ohne protein pulver ist es einfach
ein gesundes frühstück also macht es
super super gerne nacht jetzt so noch
ein tipp ich mag das gerne mit hafer
milch ich habe gemerkt wenn ich kuhmilch
nehme dann brauche ich auf jeden fall
ein süßungsmittel in dem fall habe ich
ja wohl nicht rein gemacht wenn ich habe
mich nehme dann las ich auch den honig
komplett weg weil dann ist mir das schon
süß genug aber das könnt ihr für euch
entscheidend ich mache jetzt einfach mal
weiter mit dem nächsten rezept das kommt
noch mal an die seite und wie man jetzt
einfach brot mit avocado und das habe
ich nur für mich entdeckt das ist er
seine inspiration wenn ihr ein gutes
vollkornbrot nehmt dann habt ihr auch
noch gesunde fette wegen der avocado
natürlich auch wegen den eiern das
eiweiß also ist eigentlich ein
rundum-paket dafür mache ich zuallererst
mal die barcarole dann nehme ich mir
jetzt hier eine reife avocado und dann
wird dir einfach nur mit einer gabel
schön zermatscht da kommt nur ein
bisschen salz pfeffer und ein bisschen
zitronensaft mit rein
[Musik]
jetzt werde ich zwei eier von beiden
seiten einmal anbraten ich persönlich
mag sogar wenn das ei noch flüssig ist
ihr könnt euch auch ein omelett machen
ganz wie ihr möchtet da kommt dann
gleich nur noch ein bisschen salz oder
wenn ihr mögt von meinem royal gewürzt
dazu macht es nicht zu salzig denn sonst
habt ihr es habt ihr einfach durch den
tag über verteilt deswegen sollte man
grundsätzlich beim es da oder einfache
sachen essen und halt dinge die ja viel
wasser enthalten da zeigen sich gleich
noch ein drittes rezept das ist da ganz
gut geeignet und viel wasser trinken ist
sowieso immer ganz wichtig
[Musik]
rezept nummer drei ist für alle die
einfach nichts festes essen können es
gibt ja auch menschen unter uns sein
weiß krieg aber nichts runter ich trinke
lieber was dann solltet ihr vielleicht
nicht nur wasser trinken sondern auch
dem körper nährstoffe geben in form von
zb bananen in einem smoothie oder pulver
denn mein nächstes rezept ist ein us
musik es gibt ja atp im tiefkühlregal
mittlerweile habe ich zum beispiel auch
schon mal kaufland gesehen falls ihr das
nicht da habt dann verwendet gerne als
apple beachtet auf gute bio qualität ich
verlinke euch meint gerne in die infobox
und was ich auch vorbereitet hat bzw das
habe ich eigentlich immer darauf dass
hier sind tief gefrorene bananen das
mache ich immer wenn bananen einfach
nicht mehr genießbar sind weil sie schon
zu braun werden wobei ich mag ja braune
bananen lieber weil die schön süß sind
deswegen dürfte euch an der farbe gerade
nicht stören lassen aber immer so ein
paar bananen tiefkühlfach haben kann nie
schaden gibt es ist direkt ihren mixa es
ist schon mal die bananen drin ihr
braucht jetzt kein hochleistungs mixa
für dieses rezept solcher erzählt der
hier gibt langsam den geist auf daher
mache ich heute hier mit und da gebe ich
jetzt milch ihr könnt auch sojadrink
oder hafer milch dazugeben gebe ich
jetzt mit rein und fühle ich mit etwas
wasser auf dann habt ihr nämlich schön
wasser zugeführt und nicht nur das ihr
dadurch suggeriert bleibt ihr habt auch
durch das pulver richtig tolle
nährstoffe es ist richtig eine richtige
vitaminbombe protein reich viele
ballaststoffe hält jungen sagt man ja in
der beauty szene davon gebe ich jetzt
ich mache es jetzt gerade für zwei
personen daher gebe ich zwei esslöffel
rein und dann wird es einfach nur gemixt
so unfertig ist unser astra es mir super
gesund könnt ihr auch außerhalb vom
ramadan zu bereiten und
falls ihr sagt okay es ist vielleicht
ein bisschen zu laut werde ich danach
anfang zuwächsen könnt ihr euch
natürlich auch vorbereiten irgendwie am
vorabend oder so und dann im kühlschrank
aufbewahrt sind dazu noch zwei träume
und fertig ich hoffe das video hat euch
gefallen ich verabschiede mich an der
stelle und ihr könnt mir super super
gerne mal schreiben welches der drei
sätze euch jetzt am meisten anspricht
welches ihr euch vorstellen könnt nach
zu machen oder mich sowieso vielleicht
schon die ganze zeit zubereitet für euch
und dann würde ich mal sein übermorgen
geht es schon wieder weiter mit meinem
nächsten rezept alle zwei tage ein neues
video während man der ramadan reihe und
ich freue mich natürlich wenn ihr meinen
kanal kostenlos abonniert einfach passt
ja auch nichts mehr dann sehen wir uns
auch beim nächsten mal schießt
[Musik]